very much ruined Center for
delighted today to be able to post an
investor Marwan washa as this is Henry L
Stimson lecturer the Stimson lecture
series is named for Henry citizen
possibly Ogden 1889 an attorney in space
with his government service tolerated
with his tenure of Secretary of War
during local to since 1998 the McMillan
sencha and Yale University Press have
had an arrangement in which lectures by
distinguished diplomats and foreign
policy experts invited by the center are
they published by Yale University Press
previous Simpson lectures have included
political order in changing societies by
Samuel Huntington and arms and influence
my Thomas Schelling ambassador washer is
a Jordanian national whose career
spanned the areas of development
diplomacy civil society and
communications he began his career as a
journalist for the jordan times and then
served from nineteen eighty five to
nineteen ninety at the Ministry of
planet in 1995 invest and wash our open
Jordan's first Embassy in Israel and in
1996 he became minister information and
the government's first the government
spokesman from 1997 to 2002 he served in
Washington as ambassador negotiating the
first free trade agreement between the
United States and an hour
nation he then returned to Georgia to
serve as foreign minister where he's
being deeply involved in a peace process
in 2004 he became deputy prime minister
responsible for reform and government
performance and then he happens to
produce a ten-year development strategy
that included among other topics major
recommendations on political and
economic reform financial services
fiscal reforms employment education and
training ambassador will give ambassador
washer will give two lectures the title
of the talk today is moderation in the
search for peace in the Middle East and
its subject as the title suggests is
peace negotiations and everything that
surrounds them the second lecture which
will be next week on the twenty-fifth of
sub 10 but idea in the McMillan at four
o'clock again will be called the slow
process of our power reform which will
deal with reform in our political
systems both lecture center on his new
book the arab center the promise of
moderation university rules to jonathan
france chagrin perhaps prevent us from
selling books on campus and so this is a
book tour without a book stand outside
for which I apologize but you should all
I think go down to the bookstore and get
yourselves a copy after this I will say
that the Ambassador will speak for about
40 to 45 minutes and then we will have
about a half an hour for questions
comments and discussion and then there
will be a reception outside to which
you're all right so nobody can get to
listen to me I'll stop at this point
that I'm very pleased to introduce
investment
thank you so much pleasure to be here
again at the end the book is published
by it's not easy to be a modern in the
Middle East these days it has been
called the illegal trade sometimes an
act of courage or just plain suicidal
but there has never been found in my
opinion world moderation is more needed
in our area that today this is a book
about our mothers their successes as
well as their failures and I talked
about two principal issues in the book
that of peace and moderates attempts to
bring about a peaceful resolution to the
herbs really conflict as well as the
issue of reform where I believe our
models have failed the most in
instagramming real and serious political
reform process in the Middle East most
our politicians kiss and don't tell as I
say they servin government usually for a
long time but when they leave they
rarely record their experiences and of
those who do very few of them do it in
English as a result the history of the
region has largely been written by
outsiders there are very few books if
any written by other practitioners
people who are fit inside the room
giving an hour perspective on
developments of course
this book again is an attempt to reverse
this day and to give a Western reader a
perspective of some of the other
dynamics that have went on the moderate
versus the radical position is our work
and where the mother is something able
to feed successors and were they pretty
also fail to do so because contrary to
westin conventional wisdom that Israel
was the only one that only sought peace
without a burn while they are what they
are bored was not a forthcoming on
please I attempted to show through
first-hand account in this book some of
the efforts that the Arab center has put
on the table in order to bring about
such a tease for resolution to the
conflict but the book starts with a
rather personal journey through this out
of Center my time in Israel as Jordan's
first ambassador and even though I was
before then the Jordanian spokesman to
the peace talks which started in Madrid
and then moved to Washington and even
though I have dealt with Israelis of
course extensively the idea of going and
living in what was you what was an enemy
state for many many years was not an
idea that was easy to accept neither for
me individually nor for most other nor
for Arab countries in general and
the chapter on Israel attempts to
portray this human side of the country
and attempts to show again to a Western
reader some of the derailment some of
the leaps of faith that not only
individuals such as myself would have to
make but also countries in the Middle
East if we are to drink a lot in the
peace in the region that would be
sustained I would like to I don't know
this is conventional but I would like to
read a paragraph from the book that
attempts to explain some of the dilemmas
that that someone like me had to have to
had to overcome to the West being asked
to be Jordans ambassador you know into
Israel was a big honor to me it truly
took a lot of soul-searching before I
was able to accept I talked in this
paragraph about the first time I
attended Israeli Independence Day two or
three weeks after I came to Israel as
ambassador first major test of my
diplomatic skills came sooner than I
expected less than three weeks after I
arrived Israel celebrated its
independence in any other country this
is a joyous occasion celebrated by the
diplomatic corps but two atoms and
particularly to Jordanians this was the
anniversary of the Nakba the catastrophe
when Israel wonder 1948 one and most
Palestinians lost their homes and became
refugees for Arabs Israeli Independence
is no cause for celebration
president is a wise man at the time
hosted a reception at his house in
Jerusalem as he did each year for the
diplomatic corps I attended with great
apprehension thinking that my face was
still unknown I hid behind the backer an
Egyptian ambassador combat the Sunni who
had been there for 16 or 17 years and
hope to manage with a handshake
president Wiseman and make a quick exit
as soon as the president saw me he
raised his glass of wine and announced
to the crowd his great joy that the
Jordanian ambassador for the first time
in its history was present nearly 20
television cameras fixed on
correspondence asked how I felt I could
not say I was happy in his dad would
offend every jordanian and as ambassador
I could not say I was sad for fear of
offending base rails so I said that I
hope the day would come when all the
peoples in this region could celebrate
their independence the moment passed but
the scene of how I was to be was said I
moved from this journey through the Arab
center to the last six months of King
Hussein and his efforts to consolidate
and Arab center that is based on
peaceful relations he was in the states
of course in his last six months getting
treatment for his cancer and I was then
the Jordanian ambassador ambassador to
the US and witnessed some unique events
during that time including not only
facilitate the White River agreement
between the Palestinians and Israelis
but also this decision to change the
line of succession and what that meant
for him and for the Arab center as well
but there is a big chunk of the book
that is devoted to the period between
two thousand to two thousand to this day
of peace me and it's a period that to my
knowledge has not been covered not just
by an atom but by anyone including by
Americans who were involved in
peacemaking during data I talked about
two principal initiatives both of which
were put forward by the Arab Center when
I speak about an atom center I me out of
moderate what put on the table to
advance because of peacemaking first the
Arab Peace Initiative of two thousand 02
the initiative that was started by then
Crown Prince Abdullah of Saudi Arabia
and that was unanimously fast by whole
Arab states in Beirut in two thousand
little has been said unfortunately about
this peace initiative either in the west
door in our area and that is partly we
are pocketing as I'm to blame for it but
I would like to highlight some of the
key points behind this initiative
because I believe it is the most
important development that has taken
place in this decade as far as our
dismay Israel peacemaking is
for the first time in the conflict for
the first time in the country Adams put
forward an initiative that does not only
address Arab needs a Palestinian state
and Android occupation a two-state
solution but also Israeli needs as well
the art peace initiative put on the
table for major offerings to Israel the
first is a collective history and normal
relations not between Israel and
neighbouring Arab states with which
Israel has a territorial dispute but
also between israel and every single
member of the RP every over 22 of them
the second is collective security
guarantees again where Israel security
would be assured not by its neighboring
states not by the Palestinians not by
the Syrians alone but by all members of
the RV satisfying AP average Israeli
demand for security that I personally
witness for myself as the third is an
offer to end the company and have no
further claims meaning that in return
for a two-state solution there will be
no 367 claims by Adams on Israel state
and the fourth most important is an a
great solution to the refugee problem
sending a clear message to Israel that
Arabs are not talking about bringing
back four million Palestinian refugees
into the Israeli state
in all my talks in all my tours to
Israel I have always forced this
question if we have missed any through
the Arab Peace Initiative if we have
been Stan Israeli knee please let me
know so that we make sure to include and
not one single is really so far has come
off woody need that was not in the RPC
and yet this initiative was neither
taken seriously by the Bush
administration or by the Israeli
government Bush administration for the
longest time until Annapolis last year
had this notion that it is better to let
the parties simmer in their own Joseph's
and this abandonment of beastmen of any
engagement by the Bush administration in
peacemaking has truly made the situation
deteriorate and Israel also did not take
this initiative seriously and as a
result as a result we did not make much
progress even though the initiative
still is on the table and even though
with all the violence of the last six
years not one Arab country has withdrawn
signature from usage well
we tried further after or to an after
President Bush gave his famous speech of
jun 24 2013 which he laid out a vision
for a Palestinian state in three years
that is based on performance and also
called for new a new Palestinian
leadership the toppling of our fat and
the election of more moderate
Palestinians to take the Arabs in
particular Jordan which is now known as
a fact that was not then suggested the
idea of the roadmap which involved to
become what we all know today as the
Middle East roig on an idea to translate
President Bush vision into a series of
practical steps that would take us from
where we were to a Palestinian state at
the end of the occupation in three years
and we insisted on three major
principles that were all included in the
Royal first a gradual approach that
starts we'll address in Israel security
needs and the dismantling of the radical
Palestinian groups please talk to
suicide bombings etc and ends with
giving the Palestinian the political
political horizon that they needed
through a Palestinian state and an end
to the occupation in
but we also insisted on a monitoring
mechanism so that there is a third party
that can serve as a judge to determine
whether the two parties were meeting
their commitments under the roadmap or
Israel would have none of that and as a
result this monitoring mechanism which
was their quartet and which ones
mentioned in that in the middle east
road map was never activated and as a
result the roadmap also never saw the
light even after it was launched in
aqaba Jordan in in june of two thousand
or three the book shows in detail not
only the on peace there was an Arab
center but this Center really fought
hard the radical positions within their
work those of the Syrians of the Libyans
of the Iraqis at the time and one did it
and got a unanimous agreement on both
the Arab Peace Initiative and the Middle
East oil bath despite the fact that
there was a very vocal and stronger
ethical position within the artwork that
did not want this to go through but
despite this as I said we were able to
win the day at least then and put these
two initiatives forward unfortunately of
course neither initiative was
implemented and as a result today as a
result today Arab moderns at least on
peace have nothing to show for their
efforts if beast remains elusive
in the middle is today it is not because
of the lack of trying on part of models
they have been very serious in putting
on the table all of the initiatives that
I talked about very serious about
engaging with the Israelis and Americans
and the international community and
despite that fact today we are as far
away from trees as we were ten years ago
where are we today well our fat passed
away then the Palestinians elected the
most moderate Palestinian leader in you
know the history and I daresay in the
future roles and yet yet we are all
guilty of not supporting Obama's
padarthas neither the bush
administration which pushed hard to get
rid of alpha and argued that until a
moderate Palestinian leader comes it
will not be able to lift a finger to
hell and they are visionary country the
bush administration did not lift a
finger to help our fire to help
optimizing Israeli certainly did not
lift a finger and Arab states of some
Arab states did not
so either and today again Abu Mazen is
very much on the defensive it has
nothing to show for his people he could
not even get one check one from the 500
checkpoints that Israel as in the West
Bank and Gaza as that is on here at of
moderates today are very much on the
difference the Bush Doctrine excuse my
use of the expression on letting the
part is similar in their own Joseph was
reverse last year and the Bush
administration decided that it wanted to
give it a try and attempt to solve the
palestinian-israeli conflict in its last
year in office I don't know why American
presidents attempt to do so but history
has shown us own every single American
administration every single American
president who attempted to solve this
confident in his last year despite all
the efforts by President Clinton despite
the current efforts by President Bush
you do not leave the parties on their
own for seven years and then come into a
theoretic stir things miraculously to
have
all successful interventions why US
presidents have come in the first in
their first whether it is President
Carter and the Camp David Accords in
1978 that led to peace between Egypt and
Israel or whether it is President Bush
Senior with him a treat peace conference
that led to the present long round of
negotiations both these efforts came
from presidents in the first and so if I
can make a modest the modest prediction
I would predict that the current effort
would fail and the new administration
would have to deal with the arab-israeli
conflict again so how how do we move
forward I believe that America which in
the last seven or eight years has really
focused its efforts in the middle e on
Iraq Iran and Afghanistan extended to
compartmentalize these issues to deal
with the issue of peace as if it is
totally separate from reform as if it is
totally suffered from terrorism and the
results have been clear to us all all
these issues have very clear in turning
and unless we deal with in a
comprehensive plan and understand that
piece affects the process of reform and
affects the process of or the fight
against terrorism if we don't understand
that if America continues to
compartmentalize issues we will continue
to have one failure after yaad upon
peacemaking in particular I will argue
that the gradual approach to peacemaking
and I'm a product of this gradual
approach I'm a project of the Oscar
processor 15 years of negotiations
between the party this gradual approach
which preach that you deal with the
easier issues first and you build trust
through that among the parties until
such a time when the trust allows you to
tackle the more difficult issues such as
Jerusalem or refugees or an end to the
occupation this gradual approach has
exhaust before it's possibly yes there
is no question in my mind that it has
achieved many successes in mutual
recognition among the parties in the
break down of barriers in negotiations
between the Palestinians and Israelis
but also between Israel and and some
other states in the peace treaty between
Israel and Jordan despite all these
successes today 15 years later mutual
trust among the parties is at an
all-time low and I doubt that any amount
of negotiation between the two parties
will get us near final settlement that
is this
from what the parties have already
agreed to through negotiations among I
will play that we are not in need of a
political solution because such a
political solution exists today it
exists not because of an imposition from
the United States of anyone but because
of negotiations of frameworks that have
been arrived at among the parties
themselves when President Clinton
offered the Clinton parameters at the
end of his presidency in two thousand he
did not have the luxury of prior
negotiations on final status among the
parties themselves he had to don't want
to say make them up and he had to guess
what the headlines are and he came up
with with parameters that were not in
fact what not bad at all but since then
this is and the Palestinians came up
with a number of frameworks through the
top a dog which we need a document and
number of documents between Palestinian
officials and his rail officials and the
herbs which is the most important have
changed the gold port through offering
not peace between Israel and the
Palestinians but between Israel and the
whole world through their position these
are all excellent sense of frameworks
that can serve as a basis for a solution
what we need is the political way by the
United States and the international
community
to move from conflict management to
conflict resolution because if we don't
do that and if we don't do that quickly
the radical forces in the art world are
rising at an alarming rate and next time
you want to have negotiations among the
parties you will not be talking to
mother it's like me you would be talking
to the running for the foreseeable
future this notion which in fact has
been adjusted by the Clinton peace
making team that America cannot want
peace more than the parties themselves
is the wrong notion America not only can
it must it must be cuz radicalism and
terrorism in the region is now affecting
as we all have seen post-september 11 is
directly affecting us nationally and
unless we change our mindset and we move
to conflict resolution through the sense
of reference that I talked about I
believe that we will have to deal with
the radicals for a long time to come and
two-state solution that I talking about
is not a sell out of Israel as many in
the United States would have us believe
it
solution is ironically today not just in
the interest of Arabs and Palestinian it
is directly in the interest of Israel
and i'll tell you one not just because
of radicalism but because of the
demographic problem today Israel faces a
situation where the number of hours
under this rains control whether they
are the 1.3 million Arabs in Israel
profit Israeli citizens for the 3.5
million Palestinians in the West Bank
and Gaza 4.8 million Arabs the Israel
today control equals the number of Jews
in the Israeli state today in the near
future you're going to have a situation
where the number of atoms would
outnumber the number of losing them
seriously and if a two-state solution is
not possible what other what are the
options does is very hard a one-state
solution in which is a gives equal
rights to all its citizens it runs
directly against the resin death of the
Israeli state as a Jewish state is that
a solution that Israel simply would not
accept an indefinite occupation for you
know the foreseeable future it will
result in not just frustration but in
frustration that act that leads to
terrorism that leads to violence for 40
what option do we have if we do not
interesting but so that I'm not accused
of telling Israel what is in its
entrance I chose in the book to read
what Robbie give in his final statement
to the Knesset in which he passed us
Lord Hawthorne succeeded in passing
Oscar be in the Knesset in 1995 by a
vote of 61 to 59 61 to 59 and no one
accused of being of being a week Prime
Minister so to answer the critics that
say that piece today is not possible
because we have a pen in a week
Palestinian government and we have a
week Israeli government we need to wait
until both governments are strong and we
have a willing and able US
administration then peace is possible my
answer is if you want to wait that long
we will never because the status quo is
not frozen in the middle east and the
forces of radicalism are not just on the
eyes but after they be most popular in
the region let me tell you let me just
read quickly what what Ravi had to say
in his final address today today's we
did not return to an empty lab there
were Palestinians here who struggled
against us for a hundred wild and bloody
many thousands on both sides were killed
in the button over the same land over
the same strip of territory and were
joined by the armies of the Arab states
today after innumerable wars and bloody
incidents we ruled more than two million
Palestinians through the IDF this is a
95 today they are 3.5 and drawing their
lives by civil administration this is
not a peaceful solution we can continue
to fight we can continue to kill
and continue to be but we can also try
to put a stop to this never-ending cycle
of blood we can also give peace a chance
he goes on we preferred a Jewish state
even if not on every part of the Land of
Israel to a bi-national state which
would emerge with the annexation of 2.2
million Palestinian residents of the
Gaza Strip and Westlife like I said they
are not 3.1 we had to choose between the
whole of the Land of Israel which meant
a bi-national state and whose population
as of today would comprise four and a
half million Jews and more than 3
million poly Palestinians and state with
this territory but which will be a
Jewish state we chose to be adduced we
chose a Jewish state because we are
convinced that the binational stained
with millions of Palestinian Arabs will
not be able to fulfill the Jewish role
of the state of this of Israel which is
the state of the gym today of course
will hurt similar statements both from X
Prime Minister Sharon and Prime Minister
Olmert that took to the same unless we
have a two-state solution Israel today
is
the trouble not the best thing despite
all this as I've said at the beginning
of the lecture the Arab center today is
deeply in from the Arab center today is
very much on the defensive in the art
world and why because so far it has been
a one-dimensional self it has been a
center which has primarily focused on
the issue of peace and despite its
variant efforts it has not been able to
bring this peaceful settlement to our
society but it has failed to address
other issues of importance of society
political reform good governance
economic well-being and cultural diapers
and because it has neither salty of
Israeli conflict known address these
issues it has nothing to show today for
example and as a result it is a center
that has lost its credibility my main
argument in the bottom other than the
shop this is that for this Center to
both to prosper to be successful and
credible in the future it cannot rest on
the pillar of peace alone it has to rest
also on the other pillar of
so far it has not done and so far out of
mothers on trees half by and large not
been moderate on the phone have not even
addressed this issue has been largely
silent on the need for a refund process
in the Arab world in the next week in my
lecture I will go into this issue of
that reform and this Phil process of
other people in great detail and first
attempt to explain why Arabs have not
been forthcoming on reform why the
artwork today is lagging behind most of
the other regions of the world if not
all of the other in terms of good
governance and what can be done to
institute a process where an Arab center
emerges that is pluralistic in other
words that believes in political and
cultural diversity at all times that is
peaceful in other words believes in
peaceful existence regionally but also
domestically more political forces
domestically do not carry arms and
inclusion is in that it really accepts
and includes all the ethnic and
religious groups and communities in the
thank
well thank you very much so now we have
some time for questions and discussion
yes sir I'm there and I have questioned
like talking about peace and
occupational possibility of development
action is nothing that this Center has
to do state either to the herbs for to
the twist like the liberal democracy and
the duration of the movement to the
herbs in the eve of the National come
together so how can what why should the
West keep supporting this center and why
should the herbs not move towards more
radicalization given that we have a
clear now alternative first one
who is this person or going but there
are two schools of thought in the Arab
world the one that says that violence is
the only way to go and therefore you
know moderation has not as you said
succeeded in bringing resolution of
galaxies and therefore the way to go is
with violence I strongly object and I
would continue to object to the end of
my life because I don't believe invite
as a way to develop a healthy society
and because I believe that once you
accept violence as a tool towards
meeting or political objectives you are
necessarily an exclusion in society and
the results after they clear to us or
the Arab world today is lagging behind
my own regions of the world we are
increasingly introverted we are
increasingly not dealing with the rest
of the civilizations of the world we
seem to think at times that you are the
center of the universe and the results
are clear it's not like Arabs are you
know it's not like a violent theory of
people like Hamas and Hezbollah are
taking us to the you know forefront of
civilization in the
it is not my suggestion is more of
moderation not less of knowledge but
moderation that is not selected
moderation that does not only apply
itself to the issue of peace and ignores
the issue of reform and the issue of
doors that is an ambitious project and
that is a project that will take 40 or
50 years i'm not an idealist and i don't
think that you you know like others may
be that you democracy springs overnight
because you throw a dictator that we
have all seen is not the case democracy
is not just about no initiated after
placing it is not just about free
election see that you have to install
the pillars of democracy from you know
tradition independence of the first
women's empowerment to the belief that
not only majority not only in majority
rule but in minority and individual
rights and if you don't believe then you
are talking about an autocracy or not
this is the suggestion that I and people
like me have and I am the first to tell
you that we are a minority today in the
art world but if the option the option
if the alternative is to choose violence
then allow me to
long distance off vissa I'm curious to
know you know the pretty where he
described where the buzz Brotherhood
might fall I did her research online
last year I know that 60 years ago they
were assassinated Egyptian political
figures but then you know since then
they've undergone a transformation their
president all over the Middle East in
many different forms I understand that
some branch of them are members of the
Jordanian legislature and that another
manifestation of Muslim Brotherhood is
of course Hamas and Palestine so it
seems like it may not be officially a
dichotomy either accepting violence or
rejecting all lines maybe a little bit
more spectrum unless your comment about
the brother I think when we talk about
what if you can't stop there's a
tendency in the West to treat but it's
business time as modern as belonging to
one group when this is clearly not the
case and if you allow me I'm glad with
us if you allow me to try to divide
political Islam in the Middle East into
at least
the first is what I will call the
exclusion school this is a group at war
with the whole world this is al Qaeda
times they don't believe in dialogue
they don't believe in France premised
not against the West up against everyone
who does not believe in this very strict
interpretation of Islam they believe in
violence means everything is permitted
if you don't agree this is a group with
which no compromise it's possible
because they are my interests illegal
this is a group that must be fought but
it is the tiniest group in political
stuff you have the second group which is
the in-between this is the Hamas and
Hezbollah this one these are people who
also employ violent means who also carry
on but the theater of operation is
limited not to the world will expect to
the world in which they have an
occupation in the West Bank and Gaza or
they also have one arm inside the system
they are both part of their a political
process in their respective countries in
the Indian legislature and in the
definition is but they also carry on so
there you know the neither inside the
system nor outside and then you have the
third group which has which is the
peaceful which has always been peaceful
some of them have advocated positions no
less hardline done the second group or
maybe but the second group but they have
always
employed peacefully the Muslim
Brotherhood in Jordan comes to mind some
of them political Islamic parties in
Morocco in Yemen and that's well done
and my argument is that you need to
encourage the second group to migrate to
the third while we fight the first we
cannot deal with political stuff as if
it is morning I think are two principal
I talked about this at length next next
week there are two principal sign this
must be adhered to by secular and
religious parties alive and I don't
limit these two religious parties help
all all political parties in the other
words must adhere to these two principal
one is peaceful means you cannot be a
political party and carried off you
cannot defeat your views by force only
the state care exams if you do that if
you allow yourself to carry arms as a
marketing with energy state you are
allowing that I try to other political
forces and then it's a formula for civil
war it's not a formal point and you have
to also
comment to the principle of political
and cultural diversity at all times
meaning that you don't use you know
democracy to come to power once and then
you deny others the right to do so and
you don't submit balls all society to
your culture or even brilliant asleep
because if you don't respect individual
or minority rights you are again not
talking about the heuristic inclusion
system you are talking about an
automatic system if these two principles
are ideal then i would consider secular
or religious parties to be part of
myself you know Islamists are rolling in
Turkey today or I consider them part of
the second because the employ peaceful
means and because they believe in a
peaceful rotational force I wonder how
it would essentially defined moderation
and radicalism
much hinges on understanding of those
times because if moderation is defined
kill the negative in avoidance of some
extremes like diversity let me know this
is for me right now avoidance of excess
and insufficiency this is a purely
negative destination which doesn't agree
the understanding of some positive term
will ends or aims with the moderates
surface new media resolutely and if you
define our motivations and positive we
have the reticle terms like well
non-violence inclusiveness I assume that
those goals need see through very
radical politics and they may employ
some very radical confrontations with
the angles of inclusiveness or or
television or whatever little on the
problem of reforms which I believe may
involve very radical confrontations with
some willders with some current builders
of power so in this sense moderation
would sell itself little radicalism but
defined well and some will substantively
I believe in three I believe I put it in
very positive terms i'll give you three
values I believe the censorship
subscribe to should be pluralistic
meaning believe in floral ism at what
time should be peaceful
you try out your objectives through
peaceful means and it should be
inclusion you include all of your ethnic
and religious groups in your society
these are the three values that to me
define the center it is not a center
that is a long secular or religious life
religion is a very important part in
politics in the middle east and iiii
think it will remain so for a very long
time so we cannot talk about the
separation of church and state in the
Western sense but we certainly can talk
about a pluralistic peaceful and
inclusive society I don't see that why
that we cannot do that at work we cannot
talk about it as if all of this is going
to come over man again you know when you
talk about about about confrontation
with the ruling elite which today of
course does not want any reform process
in doubt work because they understand
too well that this will come at their
own expense but I'm not a proponent of
you know of an overnight confrontation
because it doesn't
democracy is an evolutionary process it
has been and the connection was
everywhere else in the world the Arab
world is no exception we cannot just you
know assume that free elections will
result in democracy in the art world
because as you know democracy is a lot
more than is a lot more you have free
elections in your own right and then
what happened and then and then other
other forces were denied rival political
organized so it's not about just village
it's about instituting all the pillars
of democracy which would take a long
time but it must be started and the
problem with the political elite in my
opinion in the Arab world today is that
they don't want to start at all their
principal theory is if you open up the
system that Islam is coming they take
and therefore don't open offices what
the reformists are saying is if you
don't open up the system maybe not this
thumbs but the radicals would come but
you open up the system gradually not
necessarily
yeah when you discussed the internal
reforms left our properties accidentally
economics better jobs education use of
blood technology and plants also the use
of that oil money to lessen the gap grab
the increased again but I left out all
these and more only because this is the
subject of next week's tension I meant
to focus this week's lecture on the
efforts to bring about peace in the
Middle East I will talk about all these
in my opinion one of the major
challenges in that one is educational
reform I talked about in history and and
the quality of education not the
quantity of education I agree with you
sir what all the points out I will
certainly deal with the morning so I
scared you to attend next week's lecture
is one so let me then adjusting to being
per minute and and fall out the logic of
what you were saying about peace
negotiations which I found very concise
I found very precise if your argument
that without huge American commitment
there won't be a successful resolution
of negotiations I also thought your
point was very relevation presidents
such as Carter now
push to about such as as Clinton not
wish to that trying to do this on the
way out of the White House don't get
anywhere and I thought your point was
also while taking that it was it was
President Carter Bush one that that made
big progress and they do this in a first
term but which he neglected to say was
near than Madison and particularly now
for the revolution of reaction politics
has made it virtually impossible at
least in the mindsets of people who run
political campaigns it's made virtually
impossible for an American president
who's running for reelection to think
that they can afford to lose Florida in
an American election that essentially
Middle East what American become been
doing the Middle East is now hostage to
the politics of the election in for just
the reality this is wine say even Obama
now who's been quite progressive in
traditional democratic sense on many
issues this is you know running a very
pro-israel foreign policy and even if
you know if we have an Obama
administration I don't think it'd be
realistic to anticipate that that would
change before the 2004 election or over
and I think the same thing to be true
with a retainer
so if you take all of that as more or
less forgiving and we then we agree with
your analysis what we're really looking
at is no prospects for serious America
construction of Sabrina resolution
before 2005 whether Louisa laughs excuse
me well 2,000 buttons automatically
selected so if that is that's probably
correct what does that mean in terms of
your analysis does it mean that you
should nonetheless be pushing this
moderate Arab agenda because otherwise
things will get even worse and so you're
doing it but knowing you just got your
fingers in the dike it's a holding
pattern or does it desert perhaps mean
that the modern air to Center rather
than spending four years not delivering
and thereby losing the feeling more
legitimacy should focus on other things
maybe the economy and and just take it
as a given that the peace process is
anointed we erase some extremely good
points I'm often reminded of the first
point the needle Bush seniors
on the hot second term so I strongly
object not only disagree you might as
well that the reason they did not have a
second term was the artisan I think you
know Carter had a million others they
are running crysis the economy as as did
such machine I do not think that the
majority of Americans opted away from
Carter or Bush Senior because of the
Madrid peace conference or because of
the Camp David that's my first point
second point is I agree with you that
both candidates if you notice both
candidates today Obama and McCain have
said very little on the Argosy very
little I mean even somebody like me who
is following this on a daily basis
cannot really tell ok what the two
candidates really stuck on a lot Israeli
peacemaker and it's a sign of the times
as you said but we need to change how we
frame page because if we frame the issue
that solve the guard is very confident
is against that you know the pro-israel
lobby here we're getting it wrong this
is what I'm saying I mean what I'm
saying is this is a win-win situation is
not listen you don't make the Arab swing
by ending the occupation you may
is 12 because if you don't affect a
two-state solution Israel is in big
trouble today and I would claim as you
said maybe maybe reality is that the new
administration will not touch this issue
for you know many years and maybe the
both campaigns will advise the president
that he has to deal with Afghanistan and
he has to deal with the ark and what to
do with it and he has to do with the
Iranian nuclear option and a million
other things in the middle east before
he comes to israeli peacemaking and
that's probably what they will do that's
probably what they will do what I'm
saying is if that is the case you will
not have a chance to solve it 2,000 in
mind there won't be a two-state solution
that is possible in 2012 and maybe maybe
I don't want to be overdramatic there
won't be mothers to talk to to sort the
contractor 2012 so even if you want to
solve it there your ability to do so
would be severely diminished that if it
is not paid attention to at the very
least
but still in this discussion of the
peace process the elf in the room is
Jerusalem you don't have any vision of
other side of putting out of moderates
about what to do the true so in terms of
really bring up people beyond what
sounds like the terms the conflict the
most intractable whether or not there's
a meanie I don't think any Israeli camp
really believes are in full return of
nine stitches and lines I don't think
any Arab camp at this point at least in
terms of their own popularity never
seemed to surrendering at the
international relations be dropped you
create a picture of the outer peace
initiative is such that you know there's
no remaining issues on the table then
we'd seen the largest and thought it was
relevant terms of American circles and
girls would argue that meaning to help
is it is actually still to delay and
intractable and the second issue that
would that help it up was this issue so
incredible commitment meaning that yeah
it's great that all these countries
right the Jordan wants peace or provided
that non-state actors not state most
actors are the states are able to rein
them in right you still do have
terrorism's non-state based contingency
all of those moderate efforts didn't
nail the two primary issues so at that
point the question has to turn back in
era moderates when are those when will I
don't get dressed let me add them to
tell you what the solution would
and I'm not making this up every single
work that I tell you is a result of
negotiations yes not always negotiations
that ended with the signing on a pen but
nevertheless very serious negotiations
that left no stone unturned and I will
attempt to tell you not just about
everything else is my let's start with
the Palestinian state borders you will
have ninety-seven percent of the West
Bank as we know today given that to the
person the three percent which will be
given to reserve the settlement rocks
along the Green Line corridor will be
compensated for the Palestinians through
other land that reduce that would be
swapped with Israel either adjacent to
the gaza strip or in the southern part
of the worse part that's already been
agreed to by or all but there is no
contention about this Jerusalem
West Jerusalem stays in his residence
East Joseph outside the world goes back
to Adam something the old city which is
in eastern for those who are familiar
the world cities is loosely divided into
four quarters you have a Muslim Quarter
Christian quarter and Armenian Quarter
an Egyptian they talked about the Muslim
and Christian quarters going back to
Palestinian sovereignty the Armenian
Quarter with the exception of 12 houses
I'm down to this DJ 12 houses that
overlooked the Jewish course that is the
Western world in the Jewish quarter with
the exception of these 12 horses it goes
back to Palestinian sovereignty and the
Jewish quarter remains in Israel then
they differed over the harm you know
what do you do with semantics they
different over semantics do you give the
sovereignty about the harm to the
Palestinians to go to become this is
purely semantics because in actual terms
it's it's worth testing and you keep the
city open okay you keep
oh I don't like to use the world unite
because it has no me today is that
controls all of Jerusalem Jerusalem
United today show me how many
Palestinians venture into West Jerusalem
or how many Israelis venture into is
chosen it's not United to this so let's
not talk about the United scheming let's
talk about an open see that serves as
the capital of the refugees
they talked about 500 a symbolic degree
number of refugees to go back to the
proper today without already today you
have you know under family reunification
people going back in an unlimited number
going back to the Palestinian see this
is the second the third option is
refugees going back to the land that
will be swapped to Israel or to the
settlements that will be located inside
the West guy by Israeli accepted
repatriation to third countries such as
Canada Australia tonight state etcetera
citizenship in the countries they are in
and that applies only to Lebanon and
Syria because in Jordan Palestinian
refugees who already are Jordanian
citizen and in all objective of options
compensation for the losses of their
through a fund that would be set up over
you know another appeal settlements as I
said these settlements along the green
light would be given will stay as a
result and the settlements inside to us
back with Rebecca twenty percent of the
sentence would be vacated eighty percent
are settlements along division that's
the solution okay so you come and neck
you know you say no that's not exactly
if they did not exactly close it here
and there yeah agreed that's the
solution any solution is not going to be
far different from what I have proposed
and this solution has already been
negotiated
you asked me about terrorism you say
okay the mothers are done but what about
you know those who oppose peace don't if
you look at Israeli society you're going
to have a central movement which would
oppose all of this to you will have
people inside this door who says no to
any season of an inch or paroxysm of an
inch over Jerusalem Uganda but that is
why you change the goalpost if the
goalpost is an agreement today between
the Palestinians and Israelis it's not
going to be possible in my opinion
because the Palestinians will tell you
this is an agreement with half of the
Palestinians and the Hamas supporters
will not agree to it and the Israelis
will tell you how can we see Jerusalem
and all this one half the Palestinians
don't want peacefulness if you keep this
agreement as an agreement between Israel
and the Palestinians you are allowing
the opponents of peace on either side a
major role if you talk about an
agreement between Israel and the whole
Arab world however Hamas Hezbollah and
the settler movement will become minor
players it was on the Israeli side the
average Israeli citizen will understand
the importance of an agreement with the
art world through which is or her
individual security will be assured
forever and in the Arab world they will
understand that finally there will be a
Palestinian state
occupation and then more than financial
support for such organizations as Hamas
and Hezbollah will move all but
disappear and I believe that in such a
context you will have a clear majority
on either side yes I was wondering what
if when you think of the idea of
Radiance the writings in Libyans say
olive oil rich nations they could help
the Palestinian people and get support
for the peace process through a name for
resettlement of those people and this is
just a comment the young people in
Jerusalem do they don't care that they
don't want to celebrate Shabbat that's
all the Israelis are in the arab
territories dances on friday night and
then saturday is the Arabs are in Israel
here is theater that's really the
interest of the young in that area and
it just aggravates me that one of the
places that I was going to take the
girlfriend of mine he exploded there was
an explosion there and I was happy
because the young people don't care
about religion as much as their holders
do and that seems to be the situation
but if I'm not sure I understand
questions if what you are suggesting is
that you're not suggesting that we take
the person is enormous back and gods and
put them in Libya those countries to the
resettlement of the Palestinians in the
1i each of in the context of any trees
in the context / / / all agree
absolutely you're going to have to use
the oil money as well as money from the
international community to deal with
some major problems you cannot have a
situation today were you know per capita
income of Palestinians is just an
accountant products and then you have
this right next to that with 30,000 are
you it's a formula for disaster and the
resettlement and as you said is going to
involve major sums of money that I don't
see as a problem at the Jewish banks or
out the Palestinians look if you look at
what this country has given his rage and
Egypt hello okay since they come David
Accord in 79 if you don't calculate the
present value of money you just take the
figures in absolute terms 150 billion
okay given only to Israel and Egypt over
because of the last 30 so it is not it
is not unfeasible for us to talk about a
settlement say to graffiti problem of
that world over 20 or 30 years and not
just by the United States by the
international community why the Gulf
states while you're
and others a fund where four or five
billion dollars a year is given to the
Palestinians over the course of the next
20 to 30 years to really improve the
economic condition and get them up to
par and establish a viable Palestinian
state is not within you know it is
totally with the police last question so
just a comment about the involvement of
US presidents in peace process and this
is not in defense of the Clinton
administration but you know they were
involved beginning my caffeine now they
came they did initiate it but they sort
of help along the way nevertheless it
did materialize at the end but but but
the the question that I have for you is
what because the peace process has not
materialized so far at least simply past
three or four years the question of
nuclear Iran probably has become not
more important than Middle East and what
if you want to call the moderate Arab
relation to them it's as important as
the peace process itself did we reach a
point where the peace process is no more
the central issue amenities on your
first point is through the defeat at the
station was involved but they were
involved in the gradual approach what I
meant is that presently can only put
forward the framework for final studies
solutions at the end of his issue of
Jerusalem
settlements of refugees was only taken
starting with Camp David become David
summit in the summer of two thousand and
then that's what I meant by late
important as us is today President Bush
today is attempting not a gradual
approach but is attempting to go for the
40 thing you know an overall solution
that will end the conflict which which
good luck happening on your your your
your second point I'm sorry can you
remind you it's the question of nuclear
war on terror
yes the fact is that today in American
foreign policy positions on the Middle
East it's still around you know the Iran
issue is they are and the arab-israeli
conflict is today a tenth priority mail
put both campaigns uncertainly would be
pushing I clear that this is a major to
stay if you go to the region as you're
probably from the reschedule you can
immediately then just go and walk five
minutes in the street and you can
immediately know that the Army's rail
coffee is at the center of the radar
screen of the airport it's not your arm
is longer and it has it has also
implications on how you deal with Iraq
and how you deal with Iran and how you
did with the body shop terrorism so yes
it is a reality today that America
America is not focused on the division
problem but I am at this claiming this
is a mistake and we need to bring back
the focus of America India Israeli
conflict before in studio well I want to
just take a minute to thank the
ambassador for speaking about his book
today to remind you all it's called the
Arab center the promise of moderation
you should go down to the bookstore and
get yourself a copy and before you do
that I hope you
join us for a reception outside but
thank you very much
you